[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo el caso de una pequeña con
mucho carisma y 17 millones de
seguidores en víctor vuelve a poner
sobre la mesa un antiguo y gran
interrogante está bien publicar imágenes
de niños en redes sociales usuarios en
internet han iniciado todo un movimiento
señalando lo expuesta que se ha visto la
menor de tan sólo tres años en esta
plataforma y han denunciado situaciones
irregulares en torno a sus publicaciones
en esta edición de revista digital
analizamos con expertos las
implicaciones de una práctica que hoy en
día es bastante común entre padres y
madres pero es segura empezamos
rain el género es el nombre de la cuenta
en tick tock de una simpática niña que
con tan solo tres años de edad tiene más
de 17 millones de seguidores es
administrada por la madre de la menor y
está llena de vídeos en los que se le ve
sonriendo y jugando pero usuarios en
redes sociales hicieron un
descubrimiento que ha encendido las
alarmas varias personas se percataron de
que ciertos vídeos de la pequeña que
luego fueron eliminados no sólo tenían
comentarios inapropiados sino que habían
sido guardados un número bastante
inusual de veces uno de ellos llegó a
alcanzar una cifra de 370 mil la madre
de la niña recibió una serie de críticas
por la forma en la que estaba exponiendo
a su hija pero ésta sólo se limitó a
desactivar los comentarios en tick tock
y lo más grave es que siendo consciente
de la situación siguió publicando nuevos
vídeos
otros usuarios principalmente madres por
el contrario dijeron que ante la
situación habían empezado a borrar
vídeos y fotos de sus hijos para evitar
exponerlos de esa manera la iniciativa
hace parte de un movimiento promovido a
través del numeral 6 brain que traduce
salven a renny por medio del cual se ha
producido una serie de vídeos no sólo
condenando la situación sino rechazando
el accionar de la madre de la pequeña
quien acusan de poner el dinero que gana
con las publicaciones por encima de la
seguridad y la privacidad de suya
plataformas como instagram y tick tock
están llenas de contenidos similares al
der rain padres que publican el día a
día de sus hijos se ha vuelto algo muy
común en colombia se presentó un caso
similar un reconocido influencer
despertó una ola de críticas de quienes
lo señalaron de maltratar y ridiculizar
a su hija en los vídeos que comparte en
su cuenta y en el que tiene más de 7
millones de seguidores france24 habló
con heidi arévalo ella es gerente de
gestión del conocimiento de la ong world
visión sobre este tipo de exposición de
menores en redes sociales y por qué se
ha normalizado estas prácticas pero que
esto pone
en evidencia dos asuntos muy críticos
uno es que consideramos que las niñas y
los niños son propiedad de la familia y
así es como el primer argumento que de
fondo
y estas personas papá y mamá salen a
declarar y es que es mío y yo con mi
hijo puedo hacer porque no le estoy
haciendo daño aparentemente no es
inaceptable seguir considerando que lo
que ocurre con las niñas y los niños es
un asunto privado y que sólo compete a
la familia porque hay que recordar que
constitucionalmente la sociedad está
llamada hacia protección de las niñas y
los niños pero por otra parte está la
sociedad y están los usuarios de este
tipo de contenidos que reproducen que le
dan me gusta que además comparten este
tipo de contenidos y que van
construyendo unas discursos y unas
lógicas en torno a normalizar estas
formas de violencia contra la niñez y
eso es un asunto sobre el cual debemos
hacer pedagogía y debemos hacer trabajos
de concientización y es que los menores
no pueden decidir por sí mismos si están
de acuerdo en que su imagen sea
promovida repetidamente en internet
heidi arévalo asegura que se les está
violando el derecho a la privacidad y
nos contó qué repercusiones podría tener
en hechos repercusiones para las niñas y
los niños es que no
no puedan diferenciar fácilmente en el
momento en que desarrollan su dimensión
moral lo que está bien y lo que está mal
que se haga con ellos no van a poder
distinguir cuando alguien está
violentando los abusando los porque su
figura de protección
hizo de estas prácticas de abuso y de
violencia un juego un chiste
y además
cuenta como
con el respaldo de los consumidores de
este tipo de contenidos
eso es terriblemente grave por otra
parte que las niñas y los niños que
vienen este tipo de abusos como el que
de forma de explotación violenta como lo
que está viviendo la niña es que
reproduzcan estas situaciones no hay que
sean adultos inseguros que sean adultos
desconfiados que sean adultos que no
pueden construir unos lazos sociales y
sólidos basados en el respeto y en el en
el entero reconocimiento eso es un
crítico en términos sociales porque
finalmente lo que esto significa es que
la violencia no solamente se reproduce
se recrudece en en estas dimensiones en
que nosotros la conocemos del asalto del
arma de lo bélico sino que además en lo
social se siguen tejiendo unos asuntos
muy fuertes de reproducción de violencia
finalmente nos entregó una serie de
recomendaciones para tener en cuenta a
la hora de publicar la fotografía de un
menor en redes sociales tres preguntas
claves es necesario qué implicaciones
tendría y qué tanto puede afectar a las
niñas y los niños hay unos protocolos de
producción muy sencillos para a la hora
de publicar imágenes
respecto a las que comprometen lo que
tienen
como centro a las niñas y los niños
primero evitemos todas las formas de
deterioro y georreferenciación por
ejemplo
el lugar es todo más fotos donde hay
nomenclatura si esta es la dirección
clara revisemos esos detalles que se nos
pasan por alto y revisemos que no hay
una forma de hacer de sobreexplotar
estas imágenes porque muchas veces los
padres publicamos imágenes de la manera
más ingenua pero otras personas y las va
a tomar con otros fines y con otras
intencionalidades hasta que la revista
digital recuerde que si quiere repetir
esta u otra emisión de nuestro programa
lo puede hacer a través de nuestra
página web www puntos 24 punto com
[Música]